مثل المتهمون في القضيه التي عرفت اعلاميا
بطائره الذهب المشبوه مثل امام احدى محاكم
لوساكا عاصمه زامبيا التي قررت حبسهم
احتياطيا رافضه الافراج عنهم بكفاله من
جههها نقلت وكاله انباء الشرق الاوسط
الرسميه المصريه عن مصدر وصفته بالمطلع
قوله ان السلطات المصريه تنسق مع نظيرتها
الزامبيه وتتابع عن كثب سلامه سير اجراءات
التحقيق معهم وكانت السلطات الزامبيه
اعلنت احتجاز طائره خاصه كانت قادمه من
القاهره على متنها مبالغ ماليه بقيمه نحو
سته ملايين دولار وسبائك قيل بدايه انها
من الذهب قبل الاعلان لاحقا انها معادن
اخرى
ووجهت السلطات الزامبيه للمتهمين تهبه
التجسس من بينهم ضابط زامبي سابق واوردت
لجنه مكافحه المخدرات في زامبيا ان بين
الموقوفين سته مصريين واسبانيا وهولندي
انضم الينا من القاهره الكاتب الصحفي هشام
يونس سيد هشام اهلا بك كيف تتابع القاهره
هذه القضيه خاصه مع عدم افراج الجانب
الزامبي على المتهمين من بينهم مصريون
يعني في الحقيقه هذه القضيه منذ وقاحه
وهناك نوع من
وعدم الشفافيه سواء في المعلومات القليله
المتاحه هناك في القاهره او حتى تلك
المعلنه
عاصمه زامبيا كما هو معروف لا يوجد قانون
لتداول المعلومات يتيح بحريه
كيفيه الحصول على المعلومات
عقوبه على من امتنع عن الادلاء عن معلومات
ترغب في نشرها الصحابه المعلومات هنا
قليله جدا وربما ما هو متاح الان ما يتم
نقله عن طريق الصحافه الجانبيه
زي ما حضرتك قلت انه الوكاله الرسميه في
بطولها انه القاهره فقط لتتابع
وتتابع سير الاجراءات وفقا للقانون الدولي
باعتبار وجود متهمين مصريين لكن الحياه
هذه الاتهامات اللي بتتراوح من مجرد
التهريب الى التجسس يعني
تبدو يعني فيها قدر كبير
يعني على الاقل ما نستقبله كمراقبين انه
هناك اشياء لم تعلن هناك معلومات غير
معروفه هناك عدم شفافيه حتى في الجانب
الذنبي اذا كان هناك
نعم طالما ان هناك عدد من الزوايا غير
معلوم كما تفضلت اليس هناك اي تواصل من
جانب مصر بطرق دبلوماسيه ربما
يعني حتى لو كان في تواصل ما اعلن عنه هذا
القدر الطائي ان مصر تتابع معناها انه
ممكن تكون هناك قنوات اتصال عبر السفاره
المصريه في زامبيا
او عن طريق ربما
مستشارين قانونيين او حتى عن طريق ذوي
المواطنين المصريين المتهمين لانه
بالتاكيد وكما
سمعنا هم من ذوي
النقود او الثروه على الاقل فبالتاكيد
قاموا بتوكيل محامين فربما كان فرق الدفاع
عن المساهمين المصريين ايضا احد قبل
التواصل مع الحكومه المصريه او المعاهد
طيب سيد هشام بحسب وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
تقول بان من بين الموقوفين عسكري مصري
سابق
ماذا عن هذا البعد في هذه القضيه مع طبيعه
التغم الموجهه لهذه المجموعه
يعني في الحقيقه عسكري مصري سابق هو في
النهايه الان طالما خرج بره الخدمه او خلع
الزي العسكري فهو مواطن مدني تنطبق عليه
كل الشروط تعتقد ان الاشاره الى انه عسكري
السابق هو من يعني قبيل
ما يمكن ان نطلق عليه
بلغه الصحافه يعني السبايسي يعني ولكني هي
معلومه اعتقد انها عاديه لانه ممكن يكون
لاعب كره معتزل فنان معتزل رجل اعمال سجين
بسببك اي حاجه ما اعتقدش ان لها دلاله
لانه احنا عارفين انه في عالم المال
والاعمال يعني خاصه كثير ممن يتركون
الخدمه يمكنهم الاشتغال بالاعمال بطريقه
حره شكرا
لك ادركنا الوقت من القاهره الكاتب الصحفي
هشام يونس